this thing is called au scooter
basically it's a souped-up electric
version of that razor scooter you had
when you were a kid it costs $1,000 but
for that thousand dollars you get a
motor that will go 18 miles an hour that
doesn't sound like much but on this
thing it feels crazy fast it's powered
by a battery but it has a neat
regenerative braking system that charges
it every time you slow down which once
you get going on this thing you won't do
often a lot of people are excited about
scooters like this they think these
along with the bigger Vespa style ones
from gogoro and other companies can
either supplement or even replace cars
in big dense cities basically unlike a
bike this thing can fold up and go
underneath a train C or in a trunk of a
car it weighs 24 pounds you're still not
gonna want to carry it too much but it
can go basically anywhere with you
unlike say a hoverboard a scooter can
handle hills and bumpy roads it can hop
curbs and it's good at weaving through
traffic and the company that makes it
says it won't catch on fire so it's got
back going for it which is nice
here's how it works the throttle is
controlled by your right thumb and the
brakes with your left it's much more fun
on an empty road or in a bike lane where
you can really turn it loose the only
awfully awkward part of the whole
experience is to fold it you have this
little red tongue which you press down
to unlock the hinge but you also have to
press the handlebars forward and the
whole thing becomes as two hands and a
foot job and it's just weird other than
that it's a pretty simple smooth ride
you've got a headlight on here if you
need it
plus this really awful sounding horn and
if all else fails it's a lot easier to
just jump off then on a bike I like this
thing the idea of turning my long walk
to work into a quick scoot seems pretty
great but here's the problem it's really
really hard to look cool on a scooter
and when you ride this thing people hate
you they're always in somebody's way I
hate scooter people and now has become
one I guess all I can hope for now is
that everyone gets one of these and then
we're all screwed people and who knows
it could happen